yeah and that's okay you're allowed to
apologize to China you're allowed to
wear a dress but they're going to ban
you if you've got conservative opinions
why because they want to make sure that
kids only hear one side of the equation
10 years the 10 year old kid
eight-year-old kid right now it's a
eight-year-old kid goes on Tick Tock
Goes to School teachers are grooming
them and all that stuff 10 years from
now that kid's gonna be voting who do
you think they're going to vote for oh
yeah unless y'all start speaking up
showing up to skate events this Saturday
10 a.m there you go and just saying look
man
that's what I tell people you don't need
to come out and and wave an American
flag and scream Trump's name out loud
you don't got to put on Q Shaman horns
right and and scream as loud as you can
all you got to do is mind your own
business and just be like where you came
from all you gotta do is mind your own
business and just be like I don't know
about all that that's it
when someone comes to you and says you
know man it's like these trumps that
were so bad like they're all nasty
people just go I don't know about all
that